مرحبا نجاح كبير جدا يحقق النجمين ليله
علوي وبيومي فؤاد على الشباك العربي
والسعودي بفيلم شوجر دادي واللي بدا عرضه
الاسبوع الماضي ويعتبر هذا الفيلم هو
اللقاء الثاني على البطوله ما بينهم بعد
فيلم ماما حامل الفيلم اكتسح قائمه هذا
الاسبوع على الشباك السعودي من اول يوم
لعرضه واللي انطلق هنا في جده بمشاركه
النجوم
لا بعد اذنك ده بابا مصاحبها بس
وانا سعيد جدا بالشغل مع النكبه الكبيره
الاستاذه ليلى علوي قد ايه انسانه جميله
قد ايه فنانه حقيقيه ده بجد مش مش عشان
انا قدام الكاميرا دلوقتي حبينا نغير من
منطلق ان مفيش حاجه بتستمر على حالها وان
هو ده الواقع وان الراجل فعلا ممكن بس كنت
حريص جدا ان هو في النهايه يرجع في
النهايه لازم القيام في النهايه لازم
الحاجات الجميله هي التي تستمر مهما يحصل
شويه
يعني تطورات في العلاقه يحصل اي خلل يحصل
اي حاجه في الدنيا في النهايه لا يصح لها
صحيح هو مش جزء تاني لماما حامل هو يعني
موقف
وحكايه حقيقيه بتحصل لنا بتحصل عائلات
كثيره جدا المعالجه بتاعته قد كده دمها
خفيف وغير متوقعه ان شاء الله يا رب المهم
الورق لكن انا وبيومي ننسجم جدا مع بعض
ونتمنى نبقى مع بيومي فؤاد والعتب الكبيره
اللي ابداع تجاه منتج فيلم مطرح مطروح
والينطلق في دور العرض قريبا حيث قال بانه
كان المرشح الاول لبطوله الفيل قبل محمود
حميده ما اثار استياء حمايه اللي قال
بدوروا بانه لو كنت اعلم لما وافقت واتسبب
في اي الم او ازعاج لاحد زملائي الفنانين
عن هذا الموضوع سالت بيومي فؤاد فابدا
ندما واعتذر جدا انت هناك بكبير انت راجل
زوم مبادئ عندك مبادئ راجل عندك قيم
الراجل راجل فنان حقيقي وعشان كده انا
اصريت ان انا ببلغكش انا مش هقول لك انا
مصدقك انا متاكد وعارف كويس قوي ان انت ما
كنتش تعرف وده مش مجامله ولا ده مجرد
تصريح ولا الكلام ده انت نجم كبير انت
فنان عظيم احنا بنتعلم منك يا استاذ
وفعلا انا لما عرفت الخبر كان الفيلم دخل
صوره في يومين ولا تلاته من الفيلم يعني
صحيح ممكن الفيلم يقف ممكن الاستاذ يزعل
ممكن حاجات كتير بس انا اصريت اقسم بالله
ولما اتفتحت السيره كان الفيلم خلص تصويره
وكان نازل قريب وكليه الكلام ده انا ندمت
ان انا فتحت السيره دهيت
العربيه في امريكا تحدث فيها عن هذا النوع
من الحفلات بالذات ومفاجات عديده
[تصفيق]
حياتي لما تسويه عليا
فكره ان انت بتتواصل مع جاليات العربيه
وتروح لهم ده احساس بالنسبه لي انا كفنان
هو اصلا كان مرضي جدا يعني هو انت انت لما
بتلاقي ناس على بعد 13 ساعه طيران من بيتك
ولا 18 ساعه طيران من مصر وبيحسوا بيها
وبيقربهم من بلدهم وبيقربهم من الكاتشر
بتاعتهم قد ايه الفن دي معنا وليه قيمه
كبيره قوي كبيره طالت مهرجان جمعيه
السينما واللي بدا وانتهى وسط تغيب النجوم
حتى المكرمين منهم ما تسبب بالعديد من
التساؤلات عن ذلك الامر وايضا عن اسباب
اقامه المهرجان من الاساس وسط هذا التغير
الفيلم يعني اقدم مهرجان عندنا
وهو مهم جدا جدا جدا لدعم الصناعه طبعا زي
ما كلنا عارفين انه المهرجانات بشكل عام
بتواجه صعوبات خاصه فيما يتعلق بمساله
التمويل
لانه احنا لازلنا لا نعتبر المهرجان هو
نوع من العمل الجدي
نزلنا بنعتبره
زي فرح مثلا وسمعته كتير وانا قلت الكلام
ده قبل كده كثير
يقف الشخص
هو نحن الان في عرس السينما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات